est-ce qu'il y a des traitements contre
la déréalisation la déréalisation j'ai
prévu de faire une vidéo là-dessus mais
c'est vrai que pour l'instant on en a
jamais parlé donc vite fait pour les
gens qui connaissent pas du tout la
déréalisation comme la
dépersonnalisation qui ressemble
beaucoup c'est ce qu'on appelle des
troubles dissociatifs la dissociation
c'est quand on met une espèce de
distance entre nous-même et ce qu'on vit
ce qu'on ressent et cetera souvent c'est
pour se protéger de ses propres émotions
après un traumatisme par exemple et là
en l'occurrence c'est un petit peu comme
si on était détaché de ce qu'on vit et
de ce qui nous entoure comme si on
vivait dans une espèce de rêve mais pas
un rêve agréable comme si on regardait
tout ce qui nous arrive de l'extérieur
un peu comme si on était devant un film
sauf que c'est notre propre vie alors
dit comme ça c'est flippant mais déjà
c'est pas rare du tout et puis la
plupart du temps c'est pas grave du tout
non plus dans la mesure où oui ça se
soigne justement il y a des traitements
alors des médicaments pas vraiment sauf
ce pour soigner ce qui peut déclencher
la déréalisation genre l'anxiété la
dépression et cetera mais il y a un
traitement qui existe et qui marche très
bien c'est la psychothérapie donc si tu
fais de la déréalisation hésite pas à
aller voir un psych